another victim the left has chosen to
ignore his U.S army veteran and father
of three Hassan Correa he was brutally
beaten and stabbed to death in 2018.
even though the entire attack was caught
on camera two of the four thugs charged
in his murder received sweetheart deals
from Alvin Bragg's office here in New
York his mother Madeleine brame hasn't
stopped fighting for him though and
others ignored by the left
all types of criminal elements free to
do what they want when they want however
they want to whomever they want with no
consequences and as far as the Manhattan
District Attorney's office if he's
receiving one penny a federal dollars
you need to pull that funding until he
starts doing his damn job and
Prosecuting crime
joining me now this woman just saw
Madeleine brame Madeleine um thank you
for being with us tonight uh it's a few
years since your son was brutally
murdered the pain I know is with you
every minute of every day it's in your
DNA now
um your reaction to what I was saying in
the angle that the left is picking and
choosing victims to elevate and
criminals to focus on versus all of it
which is horrible
well thank you for having me Laura
I've experienced it firsthand
um my son Sergeant Hassan Korea was
stabbed to death right
and because he was stabbed to death and
not shot to death because you know
that's the narrative gun violence
they completely ignored
everything about this entire case they
treated me and my family like garbage
they referred to Sergeant Hassan Korea
Afghanistan war retired veteran received
and returned enemy fire on the Taliban
were the Medals of Honor
to prove it okay
they referred to him as a fictitional
character in court and they said that
the most important people in that room
were the people who killed him
and this is the type of thing that I had
to endure the torment the torture the
horror of watching
the criminal justice system delivered no
justice or closure for the murder of my
boy Beyond just the stabbing which is
horrific in and of itself and I know
you're wearing his dog tags
um what else was it about this case that
just didn't rise to the level of the
narrative that the media and the
political class dominant in New York
wants they completely mishandled it they
were handed Alvin Bragg's Administration
was handled a strong trial-ready murder
case against all four of these
individuals ready for trial as soon as
he received that case
it com immediately started to unravel I
was told three different reasons why
unfortunately your son got killed at the
wrong time like if there's any right
time for your son to get killed
another reason was Manhattan didn't have
the resources to try all four we have
the we have the resources to house tens
of thousands of illegal immigrants yes
but I was told they didn't have
resources to trial for defendants and
the third reason was oh they couldn't
prove Beyond a reasonable doubt that
Mary Saunders or Travis Stewart intended
to kill my son
what do you say to um
folks in inner city America today who
are have reflexively been Democrats I
know you were a Democrat you became a
republican but they're just born into
the Democrat Party and if you're not a
Democrat you're an Uncle Tom you're a
sellout as a black person what do you
say to them given the pain that so many
in inner city America run by Liberals
are feeling today well you know um we've
been voting Democrat for Generations
we have got nothing in return for our
votes dilapidated housing failing
schools crime poverty abortion okay on
and on and on
but we continue
to just give our vote away for nothing
in return and I'm going to quote
something that Trump said
what do we have to lose by giving the
other side a chance how would we know
what we're going to get when we never
gave them a chance okay we have nothing
to lose we don't have anything
all right welfare
food stamps
nothing unemployment
death destruction and self-destimation
is what we have
and at this point I feel that it's
intentional
we have a mayor
who comes to the hood only when he wants
the votes
and he is a completely abandoned
the black and brown Community well the
black and brown Community tonight I hope
is listening to this we're going to get
this all out on social media as well
everyone's got to wake up this is a
country you have to save this is a
people we have to save uh Madeline thank
you uh our condolences continue to you
and your family you're an amazing
Warrior and you're you're serving your
son's memory incredibly courageously
thank you thank you so much for having
me hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else